[Musik]
guten Abend liebe Zuschauer zweites
deutsches Fernsehen an diesem Donnerstag
zu einer sehr besonderen Sendung es ist
gespenstisch im Stadion in Qatar jubeln
iranische Fans während bei Ihnen zu
Hause auf den Straßen Menschen
totgeprügelt werden in Katar diskutieren
die Deutschen über eine Kapitänsbinde
aber dem müller-regime im Iran wollen
sie nicht die rote Karte zeigen das
Mitleid ist groß mit jungen Menschen
Männern und vor allem Frauen die für
ihre Freiheit kämpfen und sterben helfen
würden Ihnen alle gern nur wie kuschelt
der Westen vor dem Iran das fragen wir
uns und diese Menschen
Parteivorsitzender der Grünen und in
Teheran geboren
die Publizistin Alice Schwarzer
Friedrich Merz CDU-Vorsitzender
zdf-korrespondentin goline
[Musik]
und düsenker Menschenrechtsaktivisten
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner
und die begrüßt alle Gäste noch mal sehr
herzlich zu einer sehr besonderen
Sendung die WM ist für die Iraner vorbei
Gewalt und Repressionen sind es nicht
Mitte September wird die 22-Jährige
Massa Amini von der Sittenpolizei
verhaftet angeblich trägt sie ihr
Kopftuch nicht ordnungsgemäß im
Polizeigewahrsam bricht sie zusammen
drei Tage später ist sie tot seit dem
reißen die Proteste nicht ab
Frauen demonstrieren gegen die
Staatswillkür verbrennen ihre Kopftücher
auch Männer gehen auf die Straße das
Regime schlägt brutal zurück im
kurdischen West Iran marschiert Militär
auf über 400 Menschen wurden inzwischen
getötet wie die 20-Jährige hordes Nadja
bei einer Demonstration wird sie sechs
Mal getroffen und stirbt
der Zorn der Iraner erreicht auch die
Fußball-WM
dieses Regime schießt auf Kinder Schüler
in den Straßen es ist unglaublich
stummer Protest bei der iranischen
Nationalelf doch damit war es schnell
vorbei am Dienstag sangen die Spieler
ihre Hymne wieder mit wohl auf massiven
Druck aus teeran
Collini ATA ist bei uns
zdf-korrespondentin im Nahen Osten
golini sie kommen gerade aus Katar beim
Spiel gegen die USA waren viele
iranische Fans was waren das für
Menschen konnten sie mit denen sprechen
ja ich konnte mit einigen sprechen es
waren
zunehmend mehr regime-anhänger dabei es
waren staatsjournalisten dabei es waren
was sie schmelzen dabei es waren
sozusagen Jubelperser dabei wenn man so
schön sagt aber es waren auch sehr viele
Iraner Iranerinnen dabei die schon
länger diese Tickets gebucht hatten und
die ein Zeichen setzen wollten ins
Stadion gehen wollten und sagen wir sind
hier weil wir die Stimme des Volkes sind
wir sind hier weil wir auf die Opfer
dieses Regimes hinweisen wollen und
unter diesen Opfern fanden sich auch
sehr viele glühende Fußballfans die
iranischen Fußballer darüber haben wir
schon gesprochen hatten vor dem Spiel
die Hymne nicht gesungen vor dem ersten
Spiel wie hat man sie dann wieder auf
Linie gebracht
das darüber kann ich nur Mutmaßungen
anstellen also es gibt mehrere leaks die
jetzt bekannt geworden sind von der den
revolutionskarten nahestehenden
Nachrichtenagentur Faas und da ist die
Rede davon dass natürlich Druck ausgeübt
wurde auf den Trainer Carlos das chiros
versprochen hat die Spieler zu
kontrollieren damit es keine politischen
Äußerungen gibt außerdem wissen wir dass
vermieden werden sollte dass die
Familien der Spieler des die Spieler
selbst irgendwie in Kontakt treten mit
der Außenwelt sondern dass sie sich eben
in Katar immer wieder isolieren und
keine Interviews ausländischen Medien
geben ja Friedrich Merz ist bei uns der
Parteivorsitzende der
CDU-Fraktionsvorsitzender von cdu/csu er
hat sie haben vor der Fußball gesagt
diese Weltmeisterschaft ist ein Sport
Ereignis und keine politische
Demonstration zu Veranstaltung hätte das
auch für die Iraner gelten sollen für
die geht es um Leben und Tod ne es war
natürlich zunächst einmal oder ist ein
Sport Ereignis für die deutsche
Nationalmannschaften leider vorbei aber
selbstverständlich ist jeder Sport auch
politisch es ist eben nur die Frage ob
man eine Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft in
einem Land wie Katar machen kann und
dann nicht von vornherein einkalkulieren
muss dass man in der Meinungsfreiheit
beschränkt wird und dass man eben die
Dinge die man sagen würde wenn bei uns
eine Fußballweltmeisterschaft
stattfindet und die selbstverständlich
wären eben da nicht selbstverständlich
sind ich glaube wir müssen einen Schritt
weiter zurückgehen und die Frage stellen
was ist da eigentlich passiert was hat
die FIFA eigentlich gemacht mit der
Vergabe dieser Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft
an Katana da sind 250 Milliarden
offensichtlich im Spiel gewesen auch mit
nur repor ist bei uns einer der zwei
Vorsitzenden von Bündnis 90 die Grünen
Henry pur wenn man in Catan nun also Gas
kaufen kann dann kann man da eigentlich
auch eine Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft
machen ist es in der grünen Logik
zwangsläufig das ist auf der einen Seite
illusorisch zu glauben dass bei einem
Verband wie Fifa 211 Mitglieder die
allermeisten nicht demokratisch dass man
grundsätzlich solche Spiele nur
Demokratien abhalten kann aber
gleichzeitig gibt es halt massive
Gegenstände beim Bau der Stadien bei der
Frage der rechte derjenigen die die
Stadien gebaut haben bei der Frage von
Meinungsfreiheit Frau atai hat es gerade
eben gesagt es gab so viele auch
iranische Fans die einfach nur
T-Shirt anhatten auf den freiheitsstand
die dann abgeführt wurden teilweise mit
kleinen Kindern an der Hand und das sind
die Dinge bei denen man den Weltverband
auch Belangen muss wenn die solche
Spiele ausrichten lassen in einer
solchen Ort und dann auch noch mit der
morschelein bei der Vergabe dann müssen
Sie auch die Verantwortung dafür
übernehmen jetzt haben sie den zweiten
Teil meiner Frage geschickt umgangen wir
haben auf der einen Seite eine
bundesaußenministerin die die Moral hole
hochhält und auf der anderen Seite einen
Bundeswirtschaftsminister der gerade
super findet dass er katarisches Gas
eingekauft hat
gibt es irgendwie auch also was ist das
sonst als Heuchelei das ist auf der
einen Seite die Energieversorgung
gewährleisten die nicht krisenfest war
in diesem Land und die wir jetzt gerade
retten und der anderen Seite auf keinen
Fall uns mundtot machen lassen es gibt
ganz viele Leute die sagen wir haben
euch Gasverkauf warum spricht ihr über
die Menschenrechte bei uns das hat ganz
viel miteinander zu tun aber was halt
nicht geht ist dass wir in einer Notlage
Gas einkaufen und an gleichzeitig von
den diktieren lassen dass wir nicht
darüber sprechen wie viel Leute über in
den beibau der Stadien gestorben sind
was mit den Homosexuelle denken
wie wir es bestellt ist in Katar in der
Frage der meinungsfrei eine faire
Arbeitsteilung jedenfalls scheint das
nicht zu sein zwischen beiden bei uns
ist Alice Schwarzer in zwei Tagen ja
ihrem 80 Geburtstag entgegen schauen und
deshalb heute in Köln bei einer großen
Festveranstaltung wir schalten Sie gerne
in diese Sendung und freuen uns sehr
dass Sie bei uns ist Alice über die one
love-binde in Katar wurde ausgiebig
diskutiert hilft das ihrer Meinung nach
den Menschen in ihrer
ich weiß nicht ich finde das sehr
verlogen das Problem ist ja das Problem
ist dass der Westen seit 43 Jahren
wegschaut
und wir immer wirtschaftliche und andere
Interessen höher gewertet haben und
diesen wirklich extrem blauäugigen Atom
Deal auf den gesetzt haben es ist ja
nicht vorstellbar dass ein Land wie Iran
nicht um jeden Preis versuchen wird an
an Atom zu kommen weil das ist natürlich
die größte Garantie dafür dass man bei
ihnen nicht einmarschieren kann und
genauso
von all dem ich darf doch eben die
Frauen erwähnen weil es war zu Recht von
den Zwergen Zwangsarbeitern Gerede und
und von Homosexuellen alles richtig aber
die Hälfte der Bevölkerung in Katar ist
entrechtet und unterdrückt ja und umso
besser dass sie darauf aufmerksam machen
und genau eine solche junge Frau darf
ich Ihnen jetzt vorstellen es sind vor
allen Dingen sie die im Iran gerade auf
die Straße gehen
ist wunderbarerweise heute bei uns und
hier im Studio weil es ihr gelungen ist
den Iran zu verlassen it's great to have
you heard tonight
was haben sie auf den Straßen erlebt
nun
aber auch in dem Protesten auf der
Straße teilgenommen
und eines Abends war so dass wir auch
wieder raus auf die Straße sind aber
meine Freunde noch mit dabei
[Musik]
nachdem wir einige Minuten in der Straße
gelaufen waren sind wir zurück und haben
uns umgeschaut
und da waren ungefähr 300 Leute hinter
uns wir haben uns selber angeschaut und
wir haben uns wirklich große Sorgen
gemacht die Wächter kamen dann sie haben
mit Lasern in unsere Gesichter
gerichtet und wir sind weggerannt die
sind auch gerannt dann sind wir getrennt
worden voneinander ich bin übrigens
angeschossen worden mit einem Paintball
in der Sekunde war ich so Furcht erfüllt
dass ich mir dachte vielleicht sterbe
ich jetzt ich habe den Nacken gefasst
oben zu sehen ob da irgendwelches Blut
von mir ist und ich bin weiter gerannt
einer der Wächter hat mich von hinten
getreten ich bin gestolpert und gefallen
ich habe diese Bluter Prellungen immer
noch
und jemand hat einen seine Autotür
geöffnet und hat zu mir gesagt komm hier
rein setz dich in mein Auto er hat dann
die Tür abgeschlossen und hat den
Wächter nicht erlaubt dass sie mich
kriegen ja und das ist nur ein Beispiel
dessen was ich in den Straßen gesehen
habe haben sie das auch festhalten
können sie arbeiten als Fotografen haben
sie versucht diese Situation auch
festzuhalten natürlich nie nicht die in
denen sie verwundet wurden da waren sie
mit etwas anderem befasst
einmal war so dass ich mit einem leeren
Telefon auf dem nichts drauf war
rausgegangen bin und wollte dass sie
machen die Dinge die um mich herum
passiert sind die die schockiert mich so
unglaublich dass ich meinen Körper fast
gar nicht mehr bewegen und mich rühren
konnte ich habe mir gedacht wenn
irgendetwas passiert dann muss ich
einfach nur Rennen
und na ja wissen sie und deswegen bin
ich so stolz auf die Menschen die Bilder
machen die Videos machen die sind so
mutig in dem Moment in dem man das macht
ist das wirklich unglaublich toll ihre
Mutter arbeitet als Journalistin in Iran
sie sitzt seit zwei Jahren in dem
berüchtigten evil Gefängnis in Teheran
was wissen Sie über sie wie können Sie
vielleicht Kontakt halten wie geht es
dir
meine Mutter
ist eine Journalistin und eine
Fotografin und sie ist auch eine
Frauenrecht Aktivistin schon seit vielen
Jahren sie befindet sich seit zwei
Jahren im Gefängnis
und sie muss noch ein weiteres Jahr im
Gefängnis absetzen
hierher gekommen bin es ist ein bisschen
schwierig geworden mit ihren Kontakt zu
treten aufgrund der Situation mit dem
Internet im Iran und es gibt da so viele
Filter und oft ist das Internet
gedrosselt die Verbindung ist mein Vater
mein Vater befindet sich in Teheran und
sie ruft aus dem Gefängnis meinen Vater
an sie macht das jeden Tag 10 Minuten
geht das das ist eine Situation im
Frauengefängnis Evin die dürfen nur zehn
Minuten pro Tag telefonieren und mein
Vater ruft mich dann mit einem zweiten
Telefon an und dann stell die
Lautsprecher an und wir können
miteinander sprechen das ist wirklich
total wichtig was würden Sie sich
wünschen an Unterstützung aus dem Westen
womit können die Menschen am meisten
helfen
nun
I say thating
sage die Dinge die schon so oft
angesprochen worden sind
jetzt sind zwei Monate rum und die Dinge
die ich sagen werde hat schon haben so
viele gesagt das wichtige hierbei ist
man sollte die iranische Regierung
isolieren
man sollte das Regime isolieren
man sollte mit ihnen nicht verhandeln
man sollte mit ihnen überhaupt nicht
sprechen unterstützen sie die Menschen
unterstützen sie die Leute die haben ihr
Leben dass sie aufs Spiel setzen
was sonst sollen sie noch machen um die
Unterstützung der anderen Länder zu
bekommen sie sind erfolgreiche nach
Deutschland gekommen
wie kann man die Menschen helfen wie
kann man ihnen helfen jetzt hier zu
bleiben oder auch wieder zurückzugehen
in Iran eines Tages
wünsche ich mir dass der Iran ein freies
Land wird das niemand in den Iran
verlassen muss aber in der Situation
jetzt ist das wichtige dass unsere
Menschen dort unterstützt werden und
auch die Studenten gehen ja auf die
Straße wenn
also etwas passieren könnte dass die
Leute eben nicht als Flüchtlinge kommen
sondern vielleicht als
studentenstudentinnen in die
Universitäten hierher kommen können
und dann können Sie auch zeigen und das
machen worin sie gut sind geben Sie
ihnen eine Stimme lassen Sie sie
studieren geben Sie ihnen Arbeitsplätze
diese Dinge
behandeln Sie sie nicht als Flüchtlinge
ja es ist toll dass sie heute bei uns
sind
abdullahi wir bewundern sie sehr und
sind sehr froh dass sie heute unser Gast
sind und damit gehe ich zurück in die
Runde und wir sind genau bei der Frage
Friedrich Merz die Menschen die jetzt
wie Frau Abdullah aus Persien aus dem
Iran kommen
sollten wir alles Mögliche tun und sie
eben vor allen Dingen in diesem Land
aufnehmen sie sind nicht in mit dem
klassischen
in ein klassisches Asylverfahren zu
schicken sondern Ihnen hier Hilfe zu
gewähren
dass wir doch alle wirklich voller
Bewunderung sind was diese Frauen dort
vor allen Dingen die Frauen im Rahmen
für einen Mut haben auf die Straße zu
gehen und sich gegen dieses Regime zur
Wert zu setzen das ist doch wirklich
bewundernswert und ich glaube manchmal
kommt das hier bei uns nicht so richtig
zum Ausdruck wir merken vielleicht jetzt
einmal was Freiheit wird ist dass wir
diese Freiheit hier bei uns haben und zu
dieser Freiheit gehört die Verantwortung
dass wir selbstverständlich solche
Menschen hier auch aufnehmen
ja in jedenfalls einen Schutzstatus
geben der Ihnen den Aufenthalt in
Deutschland ermöglicht Studium
Arbeitsplatz in Deutschland ermöglicht
ich finde das ist eine
selbstverständliche humanitäre
Verpflichtung ist in Teheran geboren sie
sind als 11-jähriger nach Deutschland
gekommen mit ihren Eltern sie haben
Verwandte und Freunde natürlich in Iran
und logischerweise auch hier und Sie
können nicht überhören wie groß die
Kritik daran ist wie lange diese
Bundesregierung gebraucht hat um zu
reagieren auf die Proteste in ihrer
wohin veratmen sie das
es ist zum Mäusemelken wie langsam das
geht und das liegt nicht an der
Bundesregierung das liegt einmal daran
dass ganz viele der Entscheidungen der
druckentscheidungen in der EU abgestimmt
werden müssen und wir das ist nicht das
erste Mal dass wir uns alle einig sind
dass die EU schneller werden muss in
diesen Fragen und da gibt es auch andere
Fragen wie zum Beispiel dass das
islamische Zentrum in Hamburg das
Spionage Netz des Regime sind in
Deutschland aus dem Einschüchterung auch
organisiert wird gegen
Iraner oder Deutsch Iranerin das das
Handwerk gelegt wird wir sind jetzt da
gutes Stück vorangekommen aber das geht
das heißt dass sie beispielsweise jetzt
nicht mehr im Staatsvertrag mit dem Land
Hamburg sind und das ist jetzt deutlich
einfacher sein wird denn die die auch
zu schließen beispielsweise aber auch
das aber wir sind halt ein Rechtsstaat
und deshalb geht es nicht in der
Geschwindigkeit
aber
Beispiel jetzt die eu-sanktion die jetzt
neue verhängt worden sind gegen den Iran
sind ein Schritt nach vorne wir sind
aber ungefähr drei Wochen langsam als
Kanada wir sind ungefähr da wo keiner da
vor drei Wochen war und das muss einiges
folgende Richtung stimmt die
Geschwindigkeit nicht und das liegt
nicht an der Bundesregierung das liegt
an der Gesamtlage und da müssen wir alle
zusammen besser werden aber um jetzt
Ihre Frage damit ich nicht wieder
unbewusst geschickt ausweiche es ist
unheimlich frustrierend und vor allem
ist es auch unglaublich
niederschmettern für mich persönlich
wenn wir sehen dass der das Regime ja
massiv eskaliert wir haben gerade gehört
von Paintballs also von von sofortkugeln
die geschossen werden das ist ein
Teheran vielleicht so das ist in
Kurdistan im balucistan nicht mehr so
der wird wirklich nur noch scharf
geschossen nach meinem Wissen wenn man
hört das ist jetzt gruppenvergewaltigung
gibt die jetzt in den Gefängnissen
organisiert werden und und und die die
Gewalt des Staates wird jeden Tag
schlimmer und deshalb müssen wir
schneller und besser werden wir noch mal
bei der Reaktion der deutschen Regierung
navid-kamani unter anderem ich will
jetzt gar keine anderen zitieren sagte
es hat zunächst ein langes Schweigen
gegeben als die Proteste losgehen und
auf die Menschen schon geschossen wurde
dann sagte die Außenministerin das habe
alles gar nichts mit dem Islam zu tun
und dann wurde unter lautem Getöse
Sanktionen beschlossen die rein
symbolisch sind was würden Sie ihm
antworten
dass wenn ich es richtig gehört aber bei
BBC News
Baby
also persisch ähm
festgestellt wurde wir in Deutschland
mit die ersten beiden in Europa dass ich
geäußert haben zweitens dass man an der
Reaktion des iranischen Regimes sieht
dass das was die Bundesregierung an
Druck versucht zu organisieren in Europa
dort auch gesehen und gespürt wird
mittlerweile wird Deutschland zunehmend
in einem Atemzug mit den USA genannt und
die USA waren ja immer der große Satan
das große Feindbild und die Deutschen
werden damit genommen und das es wenn es
eine Zeit gegeben hat in dem der Westen
hinter einem atomabkommen versteckt hat
oder hinter irgendwelchen Business
Interessen gegenüber
definitiv zu Ende
wir werden genau über dieses
atomabkommen noch reden golini seit 2000
ist das nun schon die dritte große
Protestwelle sie sind auch in Iran
geboren und haben 1980 mit ihrer Familie
das Land verlassen was lässt sie glauben
oder sagen was an dieser Revolution an
diesem Protest neu oder anders ist
also neu ist sicherlich dass protestiert
wird ohne Verweis auf irgendwelche
religiösen Texte auf irgendeine
religiöse Symbolik und zwar dezidiert
auch von denjenigen die verschleiert
protestieren die im schwarzen schador
protestieren aber eben keine religiösen
Verweise in ihrem Protest zeigen
überhaupt nicht dass es auf jeden Fall
neu und dann kommt dazu dass man sagen
kann ist es der jüngste Protest
überhaupt die meisten sind unter 25
eine sehr hoffnungslose Generation die
überhaupt nichts mehr zu verlieren hat
weil sie sieht das eigentlich die
Zukunft ihr völlig gesperrt ist
neu ist auch dass es
schichtenübergreifend ist dass wir in
der oberen Mittelschicht Protest
Anzeichen sehen in der unteren
Mittelschicht auch in den in den Ethnien
die im Südosten des Landes sind die im
Westen des Landes sind und neu ist auch
das verwiesen wird das quasi die bei
lutschen sagen wir sehen was in
Kurdistan passiert und die Kurden sagen
wir sehen was sind bei Lucas dann
passiert und dieser refer müssen dieses
aneinander denken also diese Bindekraft
die diese Proteste entfaltet haben das
ist auf jeden Fall neu ist
offensichtlich auch das werden wir
gleich Düsen auch noch mal fragen können
dass der Aufstand ausgelöst war von
einer Kurden obwohl die eben zur
Minderheit gehört in Iran und trotzdem
solidarisieren sich so viele Iraner mit
ihr und solidarisieren sich in dieser
Bewegung welche Rolle spielt das für die
sie haben schon auf benutztestern
verwiesen
Nordirak natürlich auch welche Rolle
spielt das für diese Proteste also das
Gina massamini eine Kurdin ist das ist
sie hat ja eine Erfahrung gemacht die
Millionen Iraner Iranerinnen gemacht
haben dass die Kinder angehalten werden
auf der Straße dass sie mitgenommen
werden das ihr Outfit kritisiert wird
dass ihr Outfit kontrolliert wird das
ist Verweise gibt Verwarnungen gibt an
der Schule das es bis dahin gehen kann
dass man von der Universität abgesperrt
wird also diese Erfahrung die Gina Massa
Armee gemacht hat ist ja eine Erfahrung
die ganz viele gemacht haben das heißt
das war eine sofortige Identifikation
mit ihr da und das ist auch das was eben
so viele unterschiedliche Menschen auf
die Straße gebracht hat bzw zu ganz
ungewöhnlichen Protestformen hat auch
greifen lässt auch greifen lassen Alice
Schwarzer setzt 1979 das weiß
Deutschland seit der iranischen
Revolution engagieren sie sich vor allen
Dingen für den Iran sie sagen heute ohne
Hilfe von außen werden diese
DemonstrantInnen nicht gegen die Gewalt
ankommen was sich alle Fragen ist wie
soll diese Hilfe von außen aussehen
ja es ist ja eben von der jungen
Fotografin schon gesagt worden
was alles möglich wäre man sollte auch
rigoros gegenüber dem Staat auftreten
man sollte den botschafterausweisen man
sollte den den Menschen die in gefahren
sind ja eigentlich fast alle in Gefahr
sollte man wieder anbieten man sollte
die konnten der Verantwortlichen sperren
aber darf ich mal sagen eben sagt der
noripur das endlich das Problem mit dem
islamischen Institut in Hamburg
angegangen wird das ist richtig ich
begrüße das das auch Sie das sagen denn
das Problem ist ja seit Jahrzehnten
bekannt und es waren vor allem die
Grünen die den islamischen die den Islam
den politischen Islam also nicht die
Islam als glauben den politischen Islam
verharmlost haben quasi bis heute darum
gibt es auch diese komischen Sprüche von
der Außenministerin ich möchte bei der
Gelegenheit sagen also es ist ein Paket
man hat beim Iran weggeguckt man hat den
politischen Islam in Deutschland bis
heute argentieren lassen das nämlich
bitte zwei Namen nennen von Menschen die
auch im Evin sitzen und das zeigt ein
bisschen das Ausmaß auch also das sind
in Iran eine sehr bekannte
Menschenrechtlerin und
Frauenrechtlerinnen und Anwältin sitzt
seit 12 Jahren im Gefängnis sie ist
verurteilt worden 2010 zu 33 Jahren
Gefängnis und 148 falschen heben warum
weil sie als Anwältin eingetreten ist
für Frauen die das Kopftuch abgelegt
hatten die gegen den Kopf hochzwang
protestiert haben daran sieht man auch
was für ein enormes Politikum das
Kopftuch ist lassen Sie mich auch kurz
erwähnen ja für Panahi einer der besten
Regisseure der Welt ein Tief eine
Humanist und großartiger Filmemacher
auch ersetzt im Gefängnis er hat schon
lange Berufsverbot hat immer weder
erstaunliche Wege gefunden trotzdem zu
drehen und die Menschen zu zeigen und in
seinem filmtaxi teheran hat übrigens
laserins zu dagegen mitgespielt ich was
wollen sie sagen
ich will sagen das Problem geht schon so
lange und jetzt tun wir plötzlich so
weil es unübersehbar ist als wäre das
neu also das ist das gewaltige Problem
und wir müssen endlich sehen dass diese
Diktaturen wirklich
die Hölle sind für die Menschen wie kann
man ihn beistehen indem man die die
protestieren
maximal unterstützte
nachdem man so lange weggesehen hat
zumindest dass man zum Beispiel ich frag
mich was worauf warten die
Filmschaffenden in im Westen ja zum
Beispiel für japanaiso zu worauf zu
protestieren worauf warten die
JuristInnen in unserem Land sich
einzusetzen also wir müssen die ganze
Bevölkerung müssen sich mobilisieren gut
wir können das jetzt gleich beantworten
und sind trotzdem dankbar erstmal diesen
Teckel zu begrüßen die für die
Hilfsorganisation Herr war heute Abend
einen Preis bekommen hat und deshalb aus
einer Preisverleihung kommt und wir sind
dankbar sie auch in unserer Sendung zu
haben Düsen erstmal an herzlichen
Glückwunsch natürlich mit ihrer
Hilfsorganisation war haben sie heute
einen besonderen
Menschenrechtspreis bekommen und wir
sind mitten im Thema weil auch sie
engagieren sich natürlich für die
Menschenrechte im Iran wir haben gerade
die Frage gewogen nur um das ganz kurz
zu sagen wie lange wir eigentlich in
Teheran und Iran schon ignorieren und im
Westen zu wenig tun und wie sehr wir den
politischen Islam in Teilen in
Deutschland eben auch gewähren lassen
und zu wenig gegen ihn protestieren
vielleicht können wir es aber erstmal
ein bisschen ordnen und sagen der erste
oder ein Vorschlag wäre ja
beispielsweise zu sagen dass die
Herrschenden im Iran eben auch ihre
Konten gesperrt kriegen warum ist das
ganz praktische Frage an beide Politiker
ist das möglich warum ist es so schwer
bei russischen Oligarchen soll es auch
funktionieren bitte beispielsweise weil
ganz viele von ihnen ihre Geldern nach
Europa transferieren über ihre Kinder
und die Kinder teilweise auch hierher
schicken um um Party zu feiern werden
sie Kinder andere im Iran umbringen auf
der Straße das jüngste Kind was mir
zumindest bekannt ist was erschossen
wurde er war sieben Jahre alt in
Kurdistan und ähm
Rechtsstaat kann ich die Kinder von
Leuten Belangen also müssen wir an die
Organisation ran und deshalb ist das
Gebot der Stunde dass wir den Rückgrat
der der Unterdrückung im Iran das sind
die revolutionsgärtsten einfach auf die
Terrorliste der EU nehmen dann ist die
Grenze Frage der Finanzierung und wenn
man sie unterbindet deutlich einfacher
und das ist etwas was wir als
Deutschland vorantreiben dass das jetzt
nicht immer nur mit der großen
Lautsprecheranlage geht innerhalb der
Europäischen Union und das jetzt gerade
die Außenministerin nicht öffentlich
erklärt welche europäischen Staaten da
blockieren gehört zur zur Diplomatie
dazu aber das muss passieren und da sind
wir alle miteinander dran der nächste
Punkt von Alice Schwarzer genannt ist
sind die Menschenrechtsverbrechen vor
dem Unmenschen Gerichtshof auch zu
thematisieren und den Menschenrechtsrat
als Verbrechen zu untersuchen heißt aber
ja auch wir lassen diese Verbrechen
geschehen und hoffen dass sie dann
nachträglich
bewertet und verurteilt werden
irgendwann vielleicht sieht so die
Gegenwehr der Europäer aus das Westens
aus nein das ist unzureichend und ich
will auch mit nuripur ausdrücklich
zustimmen dass wir da zu wenig tun aber
ich will das nicht unwidersprochen
stehen lassen dass die Bundesregierung
hier genug tut wir hatten in dieser
Woche eine Fragestunde und haben die
Bundesregierung gefragt wie sie zu der
Thematik steht Terrororganisation für
diese Religionspolizei
mehrfache Nachfragen meiner Kollegen
sind nicht beantwortet worden es ist
drum herumgeeiert worden ohne eine klare
Aussage welche Haltung die
Bundesregierung der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland in dieser Frage den
einnehmen wissen und wenn wir einen
einer solchen Stelle keine klare Haltung
der Bundesregierung hören dann dürfen
wir das nicht alles nach Europa schieben
in Brüssel ist manches möglich es dauert
vieles lange aber es wäre in Deutschland
mehr möglich zu Verteilung aber aber ich
wir können die vielen vielen Zitate und
klaren Äußerungen der außenministerinnen
Angelegenheit nach vorne stellen die
gibt es wir sind alle öffentlich ich
habe das alles gesehen ich habe das
alles gesehen ich weiß der ist es
utten sie jetzt Minister warum sie es
nicht klar weil wenn sie Außenminister
werden sich jetzt auch nicht in den
Bundestag stellen würden und das
Protokoll diktieren würden welche
Partnerstaaten in Europa
ist die
bundesregierungorganisation die Antwort
zu erklären wenn ich jetzt die Antwort
jetzt mal aus quasi für die Koalition
geben darf ja die das ist ein Gebot der
Stunde und das ist das Instrument das
das schärfste Schwert was wir haben
können damit wir die damit wir den das
Handwerk legen damit wir die
Finanzierungen stoppen und damit es klar
und deutlich ist dass wir den Berg bauen
die den rückgration dieser Unterdrückung
nicht bereit sind auch noch bei uns in
Europa zu tolerieren wie sie hier
arbeiten
haben das geschafft und das ist in
Europa
weil in Europa 27 Staaten auf eine Linie
gebracht werden müssen in den USA nicht
und deshalb in Kanada ist ja genau
dasselbe den Kanal hier sind in allem
schneller weil es einfach eine Exekutive
Verhandlung ist einer Regierung gut aber
man Leute die Außenministerin dass sie
ja wenigstens sagen und die haben nicht
danach gefragt wer in Europa dagegen ist
wir haben nur gefragt ist die
Bundesregierung dafür und haben darauf
keine klare Arbeit noch mal sie finden
ausreichend klare Äußerungen auch der
Außenministerin und und auch anderer
Leute es ist erstgebot der Stunde das
wollen wir was aber nicht klar war war
die Katja Keule also die
Staatsministerin im Auswärtigen Amt die
eben geantwortet hat dass es ja darauf
an käme dass da Ermittlungen liefen in
Europa gegen die revolutionsgarten das
ist darauf an käme ob bereits Anschläge
vorgefallen sein und das sei nicht der
Fall hat sie dann gesagt und das war für
mich erstaunlich weil ich dachte im
moment mal haben wir nicht in drei
millionenfach die umgebracht worden sind
und alle Spuren führen nach Teheran
haben wir nicht aktuell gerade in
Nordrhein-Westfalen den Fall dass es
offenbar einen iranischen Plan gegeben
hat brandaufschläge Brandanschläge auf
Synagogen auszuführen haben wir nicht
den Fall gehabt der ist auf den
französischen Philosophen wie ein
Anschlag ausgeübt werden sollte ich kann
die Liste noch sehr sehr lang fortsetzen
deswegen war natürlich dieser Antwort
die wir im Bundestag vernommen haben
sehr erstaunlich warum ist da keine
Ermittlungen gibt warum es da keine
konkreten Anschlagspläne gibt denn im
Gegenteil ist es so gewesen dass gerade
in den vergangenen zwei Jahren ist immer
mehr Anschlagspläne gegeben hat und
immer mehr iranischstämmige Menschen in
Westeuropa in den USA im visiertes
iranischen Geheimdienst sind was ist die
Ursache Alice schwarze hatte das vorhin
angedeutet dass es eben auch da
offensichtlich nicht an blinden Fleck
aber einen sagen wir wenigstens halb
geschlossenes Auge vor allen Dingen bei
den Grünen geben soll ist es in ihren
Augen genauso es gibt sehr viele
festgefahrene Denkstrukturen von denen
wir uns nur ganz ganz schwer
verabschieden können also wir brauchen
so wie wir in der Russland Politik eine
Zeiten wenn der erlebt haben brauchen
wir auch in der Iran Politik eine Zeiten
werden wir müssen uns davon
verabschieden dass die reforma im Iran
noch irgendeine Glaubwürdigkeit
besetzten ich das ist sehr schwer dass
wir das in den Köpfen irgendwie
realisieren das ist uns bewusst wird wir
brauchen wirklich eine wir müssen
niemanden
im Iran wir müssen einfach auch
realisieren so wie Russland sein
propaganda-krieg hier im Westen ausgeübt
hat und durch eine Art softpower hier
auch hinein gewirkt hat in die
politischen Zirkel in die akademischen
Zirkel genauso hat Iran Einfluss
Operationen hier gehabt und hat sie
immer auch immer noch und das müssen wir
uns klar machen dass wir diese Einfluss
Operation erkennen dass wir die Personen
die dahinter sind erkennen dass wir mit
denen nicht mehr politisch
zusammenarbeiten dass wir dass wir
wissen welche Kreise das sind welche
akademischen Kreise die bestimmte
talking points des Regimes hier immer
weiter gebracht haben ohne dass wir das
jemals wirklich an die verstanden haben
also ohne dass wir es verstanden haben
oder angezweifelt haben können Sie ein
Beispiel dafür finden
ich kann Ihnen jetzt sehr viele
Beispiele nennen ich kann Ihnen auch
sagen dass ich nicht wirkliche Hinweise
habe ob es wirklich zu einem Bruch
gekommen ist im Auswärtigen Amt mit
bestimmten Experten mit denen man
jahrelang an gemeinsamen Programmen
gearbeitet wird und da ist jetzt einfach
für mich die Frage realisieren wir das
machen wir hier ein ganz klaren Cut und
sagen okay das das geht nicht da wirkt
der wirkt im Hintergrund eine ein eine
Organisation die man gerade zu Lobby
nennen kann und zwar nicht nur ein
bester Oper auch in den USA sehen wir
solche Bemühungen seit Jahren aber sie
werden halt immer mehr angefangen hat
von der iranischen Diaspora sie werden
immer mehr offengelegt es gibt immer
mehr investigative Berichte und da
wünsche ich mir einfach mehr
Sensibilität genau die gleiche
Aufmerksamkeit die wir auch für die
Russland Politik hier klären gegenüber
Sanktionen ist das nächste Beispiel was
gefordert wird bringen die überhaupt im
Bezug auf den Iran etwas reagieren die
Eier tollers darauf jetzt wahnsinnig
erschüttert wenn es ohnehin nur noch
einen nicht wirklich mehr nennenswerten
wirtschaftlichen Austausch mit dem Iran
gibt also ich glaube erstmal guten Abend
in die Runde
ich glaube tatsächlich dass die Epis mit
Politik der letzten 43 Jahre auch mit
dazu geführt hat dass dieses volaregime
heimlich Moden konnte und es ist genauso
wie die Kollegin eben geschildert hat
dass diese iranwende
weltgemeinschaftlich auch eingeläutet
werden muss und wir sind darauf viel zu
lange reingefallen und es greift mir
auch zu kurz das nur auf diese jetzige
Regierung zu reduzieren sondern was war
denn in den Jahrzehnten davor da war das
ja genau so wenn ich noch schlimmer und
was mussten sich die Exil Iraner alles
anhören was mussten die sich alles
anhören was wurde da alles relativiert
und legitimiert und letztlich sind wir
doch mal ehrlich was doch so dass es
hätte eh nicht so weitergehen können
wenn nicht der Mut der Menschen im Iran
die über zwei Monaten ihr Leben aufs
Spiel setzen und uns plötzlich mit
Bildern konfrontieren die wir nie für
möglich gehalten hätten die ein Albtraum
sind für dieses Regime wenn die Frauen
sich beispielsweise die Kopftücher
abnehmen und sagen Ginger Azadi jindian
also die bedeutet den Untergang für so
einen Regime und Unrechtsregime und
Despoten weltweit und deswegen fürchten
sie das auch so sehr und auch wenn wir
auch noch ganz zaghaft anfangen mit
dieser Iran Wende die definitiv
eingeleitet werden muss im übrigen auch
zum eigenen Schutz also wenn ihr euch
schon nicht dafür interessiert was den
Menschen im Iran passiert und wie dort
gemordet wird und dass dort eine ganze
tiktok Generation über die Klippe
springt und 455 Menschen getötet worden
sind in den letzten zwei Tagen 16
Minuten aufgehängt worden sind die Reden
über ein Regime was Menschen erhängt
sozusagen ein ein
LKWs und Autos aufhängt beispielsweise
die Vergewaltigung als Kriegswaffe wird
erst legitimiert und verifizieren
darüber schreibt wenn Aktivisten das
machen dann heißt es woher kommt die
Quelle ist verifiziert auch noch mal so
ein Ding wo ich so denke beliebte wirkte
und es ist dem Mut anderen Menschen ich
glaube dem opferan zu verdanken dass wir
überhaupt konfrontiert werden mit einer
neuen Lebenswirklichkeit und die tut
tatsächlich weh und die tut auch in
Europa weh die tut deswegen weh weil der
Iran eine Gefahr ist für die eigenen
Menschen aber natürlich auch Terror nach
außen drängt und das merken wir ja auch
wenn vor dem Botschaften demonstriert
wird dass es dort zu messerangriffen
kommt zu täglichen das in den letzten 20
Jahren 180 Oppositionelle getötet worden
sind außerhalb des Irans wohlgemerkt
warum haben Exil Iraner Kurden
Minderheiten aus dem Iran nie über Iran
gesprochen weil sie Angst hatten egal wo
Sie sind und die Kollegin hat gerade
mutige Interviews gemacht in Katar
beispielsweise selbst da werden
sozusagen auch die katarischen
Sicherheitsbeamten zu Erfüllungsgehilfen
ja das heißt wenn jetzt nicht der
umdeckungsprozess einsetzt und zwar
Partei übergreifend ja wann denn dann
liebe Leute und ich glaube tatsächlich
und dann meine ich kein Horrorszenario
dass diese Gefahr noch gar nicht erkannt
worden ist und natürlich ist sozusagen
auch die Setzung der EU Terroristen eine
ganz entscheidende weil die natürlich
natürlich auch wirtschaftlich tief
verankert sind und wenn man dieses
unrechts-mullerregime Mörder Regie
Mittelalter Regime was seine eigene
Bevölkerung ausmoten lässt und Kinder
tötet wirklich jetzt mal die Schranken
weisen will dann muss man sie maximal
isolieren genauso wie man es mit Putin
macht wir reden gleich über die wir sind
jetzt im Grunde schon bei der Frage wie
schafft man es sie zu isolieren sind sie
nicht eigentlich schon zu groß und zu
gefährlich und zu wichtig auch in dieser
Region wir sagen jetzt wir müssen sie
isolieren sie sind offensichtlich
wahnsinnig schnell dabei sich in
Russland und in China und mit deren
Regierungen neue Freunde zu suchen so
also jetzt vielleicht noch mal ein Bezug
zu unserer aktuellen Diskussion es sind
in den Drohnen die der Iran Wladimir
Putin zur Verfügung stellt sind
westliche Bauteile wie kommen die da
rein hämmert die Frage kann ich nicht
beantworten das ist ja aber es ist
natürlich jeder tippt habe und man sieht
an diesem Beispiel was wir da tun müssen
und ich will einfach nur mal daran
erinnern die letzte große wirtschaftsdel
Position aus Deutschland ist vor gar
nicht langer Zeit unter der Führung von
Sigmar Gabriel also der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister war nach
Teheran gegangen in der irrigen Annahme
dass man dort durch Handel Wandel
erzeugen kann also hier gibt es eine
ganze Menge auch ich will einen Aspekt
vor in der vielleicht in die Diskussion
noch mit einbeziehen wir haben es ja
hier sie haben eben gerade zurecht
gesagt mit dem politischen Islam zu tun
die einzigen die mich in dieser Region
wirklich beruhigen sind die Israelis von
denen ich wirklich glaube dass sie sich
das nicht bieten lassen dass diese Land
zu atomacht wird und das ist für mich
eine große Beruhigung aber umgekehrt wir
haben es aus diesem Land aus dieser
Region und aus diesem politischen Islam
mit einem latenten Antisemitismus zu tun
der natürlich auch hier in Europa
danke für den Hinweis einverstanden ich
korrigiere mich aggressiv einen
aggressiven Antisemitismus und deswegen
finde ich hat Deutschland hier eine
besondere Verschlüsselung wäre es sich
eben gerade um die israelischen
Sicherheitsinteressen zu kümmern was
sagen Sie Friedrich Merz nur jetzt auch
ganz konkret damit wir irgendwie nicht
bei den großen Überschriften bleiben was
sagen sie zum atomabkommen sagen sie in
dieses atomabkommen muss jetzt beendet
werden jedes verhandeln mit diesem
Regime ist im Grunde eine Ohrfeige eine
schallende Ohrfeige für all die Menschen
die da auf den Straßen gerade sterben ja
und das ist ja auch eine schallende
Ohrfeige für alle diejenigen die bis
jetzt verhandelt haben weil der Iran
sich eben nicht an die Verabredungen
hält wir wissen mittlerweile dass sie
ungefähr zwölf Monate vor dem
atomwaffenfähigen Material stehen sie
reichern an sind bei 60 Prozent sie
werden 90 Prozent Anreicherung brauchen
um atomwaffenfähig zu werden sie haben
die Trägerraketen dafür und Sie bekommen
aus China sie bekommen aus Russland
offensichtlich das Material das heißt
wir werden uns hier im Westen ganz
anders aufstellen müssen außenpolitisch
sicherheitspolitisch
außenwirtschaftspolitisch wir stehen im
Grunde genommen vor der Notwendigkeit
einer vollkommenen neu Definition
unserer Sicherheitsinteressen die alte
Zeit ist vorbei der 24 Februar war ein
ein
Opener ein Augenöffner so aber das war
eben jetzt nur Russland aber plötzlich
sehen wir was sie auf der Welt passiert
wie China sich verhält ohne China wäre
Korea kein wäre Nordkorea keine zwei
Wochen lebensfähig dieses Land wird von
China
atomwaffenfähig gemacht so das heißt
also wir werden hier noch mal ganz neu
unsere Sicherheitsinteressen definieren
müssen und da sind die Amerikaner unsere
natürlichen Partner
konkret Russland China Iran überall da
hatte übrigens auch die deutsche
Wirtschaft unter der patronage von
Angela Merkel hervorragende
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
nach Kumpanei wenn Friedrich Merz der
Bundeskanzler Deutschlands wäre haben
wir dann nur noch mit demokratischen
Staaten wirtschaftsbeziehung die Frage
ist ja ich glaube da die nehmen sie
selber nicht so ganz trotzdem weil sie
sagen wir müssen alles neu denken ja das
ist doch wohl klar und dass wir da erst
am Anfang stehen und nicht am Ende eines
Prozesses das zeigt auch die Diskussion
über die nationale Sicherheitsstrategie
der Bundesregierung das braucht seine
Zeit das ist ausgelöst worden durch den
24 Februar aber wir stehen mitten in
diesem Prozess und man kann nur wünschen
dass er bald abgeschlossen wird um zu
definieren was wir denn in Europa was
wir in Deutschland für Interessen haben
Werte geleitet der Außenpolitik ist gut
und richtig aber aber vor allem
Interessen geleitete Außenpolitik aus
dem Wirtschaftspolitik sag ihnen ein
Beispiel ich war mir in dieser Woche mit
großer Mühe nach einem Jahr ein
Freihandelsabkommen mit Kanada im
Deutschen Bundestag endlich
verabschiedet mit dem europäischen Land
außerhalb Europas so wir hätten mal
besser vor Jahren ttip gehabt mit den
Amerikanern ein Handelsabkommen da haben
wir über diese alberne
chlorhähnchen-diskussion das Abkommen
aus dem Blick
in Amerikaner zu Ende gegangen ist und
das ist auch nicht mehr kommen
deutschsprachigen Raum Europas
gescheiter nicht nur in Deutschland
sondern auch in Österreich die Trampolin
anders ja lassen wir Trump aus dem Spiel
der hat uns nun auch nicht viel weiter
geholfen sein war froh das war Joe Biden
zur Zeit im Weißen Haus in Washington
haben der ist noch zwei Jahre da keiner
von uns weiß was danach passiert wir
haben nicht mehr viel Zeit so und jetzt
sind wir über den Iran sprechen
wollte noch mal diese sanktionsfrage
stellen wir sind immer noch bei der
Frage was kann der besten tun außer
warme Worte zu liefern ich glaube
Sanktionen noch mal die Frage nach den
Sanktionen ist die werden jetzt immer
gefordert und auf gar keinen Fall mehr
Beziehungen dahin wenn man versucht
nachzuforschen wie viel
Handelsbeziehungen wir eigentlich noch
haben sind es 1,3 Milliarden insgesamt
für deutsche gibt ein bisschen BASF ein
bisschen VW aber ich wenn Sie mich
fragen würde sagen das sind jetzt nicht
mehr und wenigstens seit vier Jahren
nicht mehr nennenswerte
Handelsbeziehungen wovor warnen wir wenn
wir sagen Sanktionen gegenüber Iran was
meinen wir dann also ich glaube das ist
tatsächlich darum geht dass
wertegeleitete Außenpolitik Interessen
geleitete Außenpolitik werden muss und
als Menschenrechtsaktivistin und
Kriegsberichterstatterin habe ich am
eigenen Leib erfahren durch meine
Einsätze in den syrischen und irakischen
Regionen beispielsweise das
Wirtschaftsinteressen
Sicherheitsinteressen waren und
Menschenrechte dabei im Weg gestanden
haben oder warum können wir uns sonst
erklären dass China zum Beispiel einer
unserer besten Handelspartner ist und
schweigen dann beispielsweise an dem
Völkermord an den u tun ja und genau
dasselbe auch beispielsweise mit Erdogan
in der Türkei ein nato-bündnispartner
der regelmäßig völkerrechtswidrige
Angriffe vollzieht und der dafür sorgt
dass diejenigen die uns gegen die
is-mörderbanden verteidigt haben wo
übrigens der Begriff entstanden ist der
kommt nämlich aus der kurdischen
Freiheitsbewegung dass wir diese
Menschen im Stich lassen sage ich mal
und deswegen kann ich immer wieder nur
sagen wir müssen den Fokus auf die
Menschen im Iran richten und übrigens
auf alle Menschen also auf die
kurdischen Gebiete die sozusagen das
Rückgrat dieser Revolution sind und das
tolle daran ist dass das alle Menschen
im Iran genauso sehen es ist noch nicht
das erste Mal dass eine Kundin zu Tode
gekommen ist aber was ist das erste Mal
dass das Ganze
Landwirten
zurück zu dem Vater der diesen Aufstand
gewagt hat zu sagen ich werde nicht
darüber schweigen was dort passiert ist
warum reden wir nicht über die
Verhafteten beispielsweise auch das ist
für mich Werte geleitete Außenpolitik
über Berus shamara der seinen entstehen
Göttingen gemacht hat seine Frau die
gerade sitzt Streit macht das sind
sozusagen nach Deutschland hinein das
sind Menschen die hier studiert haben
die unser Wertesystem leben wo sind sie
denn die offenen Gesellschaften wo sind
denn jetzt unsere Werte wie wollen wir
denn in die Zukunft gehen wie sieht sie
denn aus die zeitenwände und dafür muss
Wirtschaft auf den Prüfstand gestellt
werden und stellen Sie sich mal freies
Iran vor mit dem man dann
Atomverhandlungen führen könnte nämlich
die Menschen auf der Straße Menschen die
man ernst nehmen kann Menschen die nicht
antisemitisch sind und übrigens auch
Menschen die den Westen eben nicht
hassen wie uns das molaregime
jahrzehntelang glauben machen wollte und
damit muss Schluss sein und deswegen um
Ihre Frage eben noch mal zu beantworten
ist es einfach wichtig dass diese
Sanktionen eben auch Menschenrecht
geleitet eingesetzt werden und dann
glaube ich tatsächlich dass der forscht
unsere Außenministerin im
Menschenrechtsrat den sollten wir nicht
kleiner reden als als er ist
beispielsweise aber das ist schon der
Iran Wende die eingeläutet wird wenn
beispielsweise auch Deutschland
Deutschland ist vorgegangen gemeinsam
mit Island hat diese Resolution mit 25
Stunden sozusagen durchbekommen und dann
glaube ich dass das ein Zukunftsmodell
werden kann gemeinsam mit der
Zivilgesellschaft auch in den Schutz zu
gehen vor den unrechtsregimen denn die
spielen ihr Spiel und da müssen wir uns
jetzt auch mal wehren da mussten wir
jetzt auch mal gegenhalten denn die
größte Waffe dieser Mörder Regime ist
natürlich Angst und Schrecken zu
verbreiten die Kritiker sagen dass die
Sanktionen bisher vor allem
revolutionsgarten den revolutionsgarten
genutzt haben weil sie an dieser
riesigen Schattenwirtschaft verdienen
noch mal die Frage Alice sie befassen
sich auch seit 43 Jahren eben mit diesem
Thema was kann der Westen kluges
wirklich tun
ja es wäre schon schön ich gebe Ihnen
mal ganz kleines überschaubares Beispiel
wir hören ja jetzt von allen Seiten der
Iran war schon immer ein Gewalt Regime
und schon vor 40 Jahren wurde wurden die
Schleier wenn die verrutschen den Frauen
mit Nägeln im Kopf geschlagen und so
weiter aber das wollte man alles nicht
hören kommen wir zu heute also vor
Jahresfrist ist ist der Iran Mitglied
geworden in der UN
frauenrechtskommission sie hören richtig
denken jetzt ich mache einen ganz ernst
der Iran ist Mitglied in der UN
frauenrechtskommission acht Staaten
haben den zugestimmt es heißt
Deutschland war dabei
das Außenministerium ist schon sehr viel
gefragt worden wie ist das ja da stand
sogar der Herr Merz der doch eigentlich
die Politik und das Leben kennt also es
ist schon oft gefragt worden es wird
Zeit dass das Außenministerium darauf
antwortet und alle Kräfte einsetzt damit
dieser Schande ein Ende bereitet wird
also wir haben nicht nur weggeschaut wir
haben dieses Gewalt Regime wir
deutschland und andere
salonfähig gemacht und unterstützt also
damit muss Schluss sein es muss endlich
die Wahrheit auf den Tisch und meine
vorräterinnen haben dazu ja schon sehr
deutlich beigetragen auch noch mal eine
Frage nach dem atomabkommen das ist hier
in großen Teilen schon genannt worden
und ein angeführt worden es gibt
tatsächlich auch in der Ampel darüber
einen erstaunlichen Streit schauen Sie
mal
2015 große Hoffnungen auf das
atomabkommen mit dem Iran
dieser Deal wird Amerika und die Welt
sicherer machen
doch Donald Trump steigt 2018 wieder aus
der Iran hält Zusagen nicht mehr ein
erst mit Joe Biden beginnen wieder
Gespräche aber angesichts der Lage im
Iran reicht es jetzt einigen so wie
gerade im Moment gegen die Frauen und
die Männer auf den Straßen vorgegangen
wird müssen die Gespräche in das spricht
die SPD-Vorsitzende ganz anders als ihre
Regierung die behaart weiter auf dem
Abkommen es darf keine weitere
Anreicherung geben es muss ein Zugang
für die IAO zu den Atomkraftwerken geben
das ist eines der zentralen Politikziele
die Frankreich in Deutschland zusammen
mit ihren Verbündeten Großbritannien USA
in den letzten Jahren verfolgt haben und
daran halten wir weiter fest
ja also beide Zitate sowohl von Annalena
baerbock als auch von Olaf Scholz sind
aus November Herr noripur Saskia esken
steht dagegen an Anna-Lena baerbock hat
noch gesagt der Iran das Regime wird
nicht besser wenn Sie eine Atomwaffe
haben sondern es wird nur schlimmer
werden für die regionale Sicherheit
saskia esken ist dagegen fordert ein
Ende dieser Atomverhandlungen ist sie
die damit die einzige in der Koalition
was sagen sie ich auch kündigen noch
nicht verstanden weil das gesagt so kann
man nicht verhandeln es wird zurzeit
nicht verhandelt
hat darauf hingewiesen dass das die
Iraner zurückkehren müssen zu dem was
sie zugesagt haben und und aufhören
müssen anzurechnen Herr März relativ
präzise beschrieben wie weit die
mittlerweile sind die brechen gerade das
Abkommen mit mit sehr sehr großer Wucht
und und
es gibt gerade keine Verhandlungen und
Deutschland sollte aufstehen und aus der
Tür gehen wenn es mit den anderen
Partner starten und damit meine ich
nicht China und Russland zusammen geht
in Deutschland kann ich alleine
aufstehen sondern nur mit Frankreich
Großbritannien USA sie wollten wollen
ein paar Namen holen jetzt habe ich
jetzt habe ich ein paar genannt wenn das
zusammen geht dann ist es gut die
einzige Garantie die es gibt gegen eine
atomare macht im Iran sind diese Leute
auf der Straße wir sehen ja gerade dass
das Abkommen das von den Amerikanern
natürlich massiver unterminiert worden
ist durch Trump aber dieses Abkommen auf
Vertrauen nicht basieren kann weil man
diesen Regime nicht vertrauen kann und
in dementsprechend ist sind diese
Gespräche jetzt dementsprechend auch
ausgesetzt und wird es nach meinem
Befinden auch auf absehbarer Zeit nicht
gehen geben
sehr sehr rücksichtsvoll gegenüber dem
Iran eben weil wir dieses Abkommen mit
ihnen wollten und waren dazu auch
bereits entsprechend über all das was
unter ihrer Knute geschieht
hinwegzusehen die Atomverhandlungen sind
sehr lange gelaufen damit es Regime
keine Bombe bekommt spätestens seit 2015
seit seit 15 jetzt nicht richtig glaube
ich aber seit Trump
es ist nicht mehr umgesetzt 18 danke und
es ist offensichtlich dass die mit
großer Geschwindigkeit die Zentrifugen
weiterlaufen lassen weil sie die Bombe
wollen und und weil sie dran arbeiten so
aber jetzt gehen wir wieder zu den
beiden journalistischen
Einschätzungen dazu wir haben dieses
atomabkommen lange geführt es ist immer
unterlaufen worden von den Iranern es
gibt immer noch genug Regierungen im
Westen die offensichtlich Gespräche
weiterführen wollen unter anderem auch
der Bundeskanzler sonst würde er Ende
November nicht sagen es ist unser
zentrales politikziel die Frankreich und
Deutschland zusammen mit den Verbündeten
Großbritannien und USA verfolgt haben
und daran halten wir fest genau und die
Verhandlungen weitergehen na klar ich
meine niemand hat was davon und allen
voran Israel Sicherheit äh es ist sicher
nicht besser gewährleistet wenn die Iran
die Bombe bekommen
aus meiner sich überhaupt nicht wünschen
dass wir weiter verhandeln sehe ich das
richtig weil die Iraner sagen damit
nehmt ihr uns irgendwie nehmt ihr das
Regime aus der Isolation damit gibt es
den Freifahrtschein alles zu tun was Sie
immer schon tun wollten die Iraner sind
dagegen dass der Westen verhandelt ist
das richtig viele Iraner die jetzt auf
den Straßen sind sagen wieso haben die
Europäer sich seit Jahren so in den
Staub geworfen haben so ihre eigenen
Werte verraten um dieses Abkommen
wirklich mit einem Paar Fond irgendwie
durchzusetzen also wir stellenweise
haben Sie das Gefühl gehabt als ob
dieses Abkommen sozusagen das Kronjuwel
der europäischen Außenpolitik bedeutet
das ist unbedingt umgesetzt werden muss
dass du für alle möglichen Kompromisse
auch eingegangen werden zum Beispiel
dass man die Klassifizierung der
revolutionsgarten nach amerikanischen
Gesetz als Terrororganisation aufweicht
indem man sogar den Iranern anbietet
nein nein wir werden das jetzt so machen
das ist durchaus Handelsbeziehungen mit
Firmen geben kann die auch unter eure
Kontrolle sind also so weit ist man
gegangen man hat ihn wirklich alle
möglichen Flüchtlinge Alter ich verstehe
es immer noch nicht warum weil es diese
Hoffnung gibt dass man irgendwann doch
an das Öl und an ich denke ich denke
wirtschaftliche Beziehungen spielen
sicherlich eine Rolle ich denke Energie
Interessen spielen sicherlich jetzt eine
Rolle wir sind dabei unsere Energie zu
diversifizieren da schauen wir vermehrt
in der mittleren Osten die Iraner haben
immer wieder gesagt hallo wir sind hier
also spricht mit uns das ist in den
vergangenen Monaten sehr offensichtlich
gewesen
ist dass der Iran mit der Entscheidung
Russland Drohnen zu liefern mit der
Entscheidung dass es jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch noch Kurzstrecken
Raketen gehören für Russland das ist
wirklich auch eine außenpolitische
Grundsatzentscheidung getroffen hat
nämlich wir wollen nichts mehr mit euch
zu tun haben und wir haben auch diesen
Deal nicht angenommen nach sechs Monaten
des harten werdens für euch weil wir
immer wieder zum Beispiel Anpassungen
haben wollten die nicht realistisch sind
okay wir haben noch eine Lehre der
Geschichte
es ist völlig richtig dass das
atomabkommen im Iran das Symbol geworden
ist für das leise treten der
europäischen Staaten vor allem der
europäischen Staaten die haben sich
permanent dahinter versteckt es ist 100%
richtig und das ist auch viel zu oft
passiert man hat gesagt wir machen das
ich habe kein ganz viele auch eigene
Geschichten erzählen wir machen das und
deshalb reden wir nicht über die
Menschenrechte Situation deshalb
konfrontieren wir sie nicht damit aber
das ist noch so sein ich weiß nicht
warum das so sein sollte im übrigen sie
haben die ganze Zeit durchgeknickt
werden gesprochen worden ist das war
ihre Regierungszeit vielleicht sagen Sie
mal was dazu aber jetzt ist das
definitiv definitiv zu Ende und ganz
ehrlich die Unternehmen die glauben die
können jetzt irgendwo im Iran
gastgeschäfte machen den kann ich echt
nicht mehr helfen sie haben mir völlig
recht es ist ja noch schlimmer die
Iraner haben Soldaten in Rostock die die
Russen Ausbilder sind Kriegsparteien in
der Ukraine das kann man nicht über
Geschäfte noch mal ernsthaft miteinander
reden
wie erklären sie sich um mit Nuri pur
dass es immer noch Möglichkeiten gibt
zum Beispiel beim Öl dass die Amerikaner
ganz bewusst wegschauen weil sie sehen
okay die Iraner die haben jetzt ihre
Ölfördermenge gesteigert das es gibt
eine Million Barrel täglich die
tatsächlich aus dem Land exportiert
werden in Richtung China gehen da
könnten die USA ja Eingreifen man könnte
sagen das ist Geld dass das den
Sicherheitsapparates Regimes finanziert
trotzdem schauen die Amerikaner Weg
trotzdem schauen die Europäer weg ich
meine das ist ja etwas was wo man eine
an eine Möglichkeit hätte zu haben
der europäische Staaten ein ein Deal ein
Business zwischen Iran und China zu
unterbinden das ist jetzt natürlich
Sache der USA aber das ist auch Sache
wenn man gemeinsam verhandelt darauf
einzuwirken dass man sagt okay wir
schauen jetzt genauer hin wie viel Öl da
rauskommt und wie wir auf die
Handelspartner einwirken können dass es
eben nicht genau hin und was machen sie
dann
sie schauen ja genau hin und wissen eine
Million besser
es ist ja erstaunlich das ist nicht dazu
gekommen ist dass man eben diese
Beziehungen einschränkt dass man sagt
aber meine Frage und die von uns beiden
werden müssen weil sie diese
müller-regime legitimieren eine Art und
Weise was ihm gar nicht zusteht und als
wenn wir jemals diesen
Verhandlungspartner hätten ernst nehmen
hier ging es ja um eine Frage wie kann
man unterbinden dazwischen Iran und
China Öl hin und her fließt und da sagte
Kollege das müssen wenn dann die
Amerikaner organisieren und im Detail
können wir die Frage jetzt
wahrscheinlich schlecht beantworten und
versuchen vielleicht zu diesem
atomabkommen noch mal zurückzukommen
politisch ist es im Grunde genommen
beendet und wir haben ja aber genauso
das war der Gedanke den ich gerne noch
loswerden wollte Herr Merz wir haben ja
eines äh aus der jüngsten Geschichte
verstanden wenn ein Land seine
Atomwaffen hergibt
wird es von der Geschichte nicht belohnt
das werden die Ukrainer sicherlich nie
vergessen dass sie ihre Atomwaffen
hergegeben haben
das heißt auch in der Konsequenz also
Frage ist das dieses neue
Sicherheitsinteresse ist das auch etwas
wo sie sagen im Grunde muss auch Europa
müssen auch die deutschen darüber
nachdenken sich Atom zu bewaffen nennt
sich atomar zu bewaffnen das sind jetzt
ziemlich kühne vergleiche die sie da
anstellen das gehört nur auf einer
bestimmten Ebene zusammen wir haben in
dieser Woche eine Resolution im
Deutschen Bundestag zum holodumor den
schrecklichen Taten von Stalin die vor
90 Jahren in der Ukraine durch die
Sowjetunion begonnen ich will den
Kontext deswegen herstellen weil keine
wird bedroht seit 90 Jahren in seiner
Existenz wer bedroht den Iran welche
Rechtfertigung gibt es für den Iran
Atomwaffen zu besetzen
wir haben aber in meine Frage ja aber
verstanden ich wollte gerne sagen dass
die Lehre der Welt ist ja nicht alle
geben jetzt mal die Atomwaffen her die
Ukrainer sind das Schlimmste Beispiel
dafür was geschehen kann wenn man das
tut das war der Gedanke jetzt haben wir
den geordnet es ist ein kühnergedanke
was sollte die Iraner denn veranlassen
zu sagen wir bauen jetzt einfach keine
Bombe mehr das ist ja total überzeugend
was die Europäer und die Amerikaner uns
da anbieten na wir müssen den Iran so
massiv wie möglich unter Druck setzen
das ist dazu nicht kommt und ich habe
eben schon mal gesagt ich finde es in
dieser sehr komplexen Situation
einigermaßen beruhigend dass der Staat
Israel sich gegen die Atom Bewaffnung
des Irans bis jetzt jedenfalls
einigermaßen erfolgreich zu werden
gesetzt hat das hat ja immer wieder auch
Ereignisse im Iran gegeben die nur ganz
eindeutig eine bestimmte Handschrift
haben
die Israelis hoffentlich fortsetzen das
ist eine Garantie macht auch für unsere
Sicherheit Mittleren Osten und wir
werden unsere Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
beenden müssen wir werden auch etwas
härter reagieren müssen auch auf die
Straftaten die zum Beispiel außerhalb
des Irans verübt werden hier in
Deutschland hier werden Menschen aus dem
Iran bedroht durch Polizei durch
Geheimpolizei durch Geheimdienste
Mitarbeiter des Iran da muss man dann
bis hin zu den diplomatischen
Beziehungen auch wirklich alle
Möglichkeiten ausschöpfen die uns zur
Verfügung stehen um uns gegen diese
Bedrohung zu werden ich denke mal wir
haben eine Chance dies zu tun weil wir
seit dem 24 Februar einen anderen ein
anderes Gefühl haben für das was uns
wirklich bedeutet wir haben ja bis dahin
in einer gewissen Illusion gelebt